big changing news overnight has been
what we believe to be the russian fourth
tank army instead of bypassing the city
of kharkiv is now assaulting uh into it
with light forces so far so let's take a
look a look at a little more detail at
kharkiv it's a city of about 1.4 million
people roughly the the same size as uh
newcastle so a modern european style
system which is now being fought over
but what we've seen so far has been the
application really of russian light
forces rather than the heavier forces
and that's an easier proposition for the
ukrainian defenders
but let's be clear the main effort today
the center of gravity for politics and
the military war is kiev so let's look
at a map of kiev
so we know
that during the course of um yesterday
russian forces have advanced certainly
from the northwest and we think
clearly too from the northeast and are
now on the outskirts of kiev
what we haven't seen so far is more than
the commitment of russian light forces
and as has just been described we know
that in the middle of kiev they are
hunting down russian irregular forces
special forces that kind of thing um and
that has caused a general alarm in the
city and a curfew which continues
throughout to today
however
we need to be clear that this is still
just the opening
rounds of the battle for kiev because we
need to understand the capability the
russians can bring to bear having said
that
the russian forces have not been as
successful so far as uh was intended uh
and why is that well a combination of
inexperience
logistics shortfalls the need to revise
their plans as they've driven down the
roads toward kiev
and of course stiff opposition and it's
day four so everyone's forces will now
be pretty tired but let's look at some
of the capability that we need to take
account on this picture here
you can see the armored forces that the
russians are looking to
produce
well clearly not yes there we are
so um what we have uh in the top
left-hand corner are
very high capability russian military
aircraft capable of dropping bombs and
firing precision missiles in the top
right corner here heavy artillery with a
range of about 24 kilometers an
indiscriminate weapon in a in a built up
civilian area on the left here the
bmp3 that's an armored vehicle that
carries infantry in the back and has a
gun and a missile launcher on the top
and on the right here the t-72 tank with
a range of its gun of about two miles
however
although these weapons are closing up to
kiev now
we know that somewhere in the background
not yet seen deployed around these
cities are much heavier weapons so let's
start with this one it's a thing called
the 2s7 it's the heaviest artillery gun
in the world its caliber is 203
millimeters it fires a shell that weighs
110 kilograms to to a distance of about
37 kilometers so so this could reach
anywhere in kiev
and worse than that
is this thing called the tos1
it's a rocket launcher it fires 30 of
these rockets at once with a range of
about six thousand meters it delivers
essentially a wall of flame capable of
destroying a city block at a time we saw
this used for example in chechnya
if this sort of weapon is deployed
against kiev we'll be looking at the use
of conventional weapons that have the
effect of weapons of mass destruction so
the key issue for the day is as the
russian forces close up to kiev
are they going to apply this sort of
overwhelming firepower to destroy the
city that they think they're trying to
liberate
so let's look at the overall military
situation again
and what we've seen so far is successful
russian incursions something like this
and we need to bear in mind that so far
the russians have used about half of the
forces that they had assembled on the
borders of ukraine and the key issue for
the ukrainian defenders is in dealing
with these incursions they're beginning
to be encircled and they will have to
decide you in the course of the next few
days or so whether they fall back
towards kiev
or whether they allow themselves to be
uncircled and
fight it out
and when it comes to that on this last
map
this is the thing that underpins this
entire campaign and the outcome of this
war so uh this shows the language
distribution in ukraine and you can see
towards the east of the country a
predominance of russian speakers the
further west you go it's more and more
ukrainian speakers
so what president putin is discovering
is that he is trying to occupy by force
the second largest country in europe
with a population of about 41 million
people at least 35 million of them
resent resist and reject the russian
occupation and with the force even of
200 000 soldiers there is no way that
you can occupy a country against their
will of 35 million people and control it
unless
you are prepared to deploy so much force
that very quickly the word genocide will
be on our lips